[Música]
irán elige al nuevo presidente del país
en medio de unos comicios que estarían
marcados por el abstencionismo en su
votación el líder supremo pidió a los
ciudadanos que sufragan cuatro
candidatos tres conservadores y uno
moderados se disputan la contienda y el
favorito es el ultraconservador y brian
ray si tenemos análisis en esta emisión
el número de desplazados y refugiados en
el mundo sigue subiendo pese a la
pandemia y alcanzado un nuevo récord de
82,4 millones el doble de personas
desplazadas de manera forzosa que hace
una década
naciones unidas- alertó que en 2020 el
aumento fue del 4%
ante la corte interamericana de derechos
humanos víctimas de la dictadura
cívico-militar uruguaya de 1973 pidieron
justicia y señalaron la importancia de
que los responsables sean procesados el
tribunal investiga la responsabilidad
del estado en presuntas ejecuciones
extrajudiciales y desapariciones
forzadas
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torres sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
irán más de 59 millones de ciudadanos
están llamados a las urnas para elegir
al presidente de la nación islámica
durante los próximos cuatro años sin
embargo los comicios prometen estar
marcados por el abstencionismo llevando
a que los esfuerzos de los líderes estén
centrados en pedirle a la gente que vote
cuatro candidatos se disputan la
contienda no obstante la crisis
económica ha generado apatía en los
jóvenes que aseguran que no importa
quién gane pues el destino de la nación
será el mismo
al sur de teherán ir a desempleo
explosión de precios en irán bajo
sanciones la economía está desplomada
cuánto cuesta a pesar de su título de
abogado ali de 25 años no puede
encontrar trabajo decepcionado por la
clase política no votará este gobierno
debe garantizarnos cosas simples un
futuro real un trabajo una vida digna
pero no nos da nada entonces no votar en
un punto de vista que está lejos de ser
único no votaré no quiero ayudar a
elegir un mal gobierno soy inquilino
tengo tres hijos y llevo dos años
desempleado los precios están disparando
deje de votar pasan su tiempo diciendo
que mejorará pero nada cambiará por
todas partes en las calles de teherán se
puede ver el retrato del favorito en las
encuestas el conservador
ebrahim raisi es como un videojuego nos
controlan el actor principal cambia de
vez en cuando un día el señor roja ni un
día del señor raíces
un día el señor amadineyad cambian eso
es todo somos los jugadores y ellos son
los capitanes
los conservadores esperan una
participación masiva si nadie vota nada
cambiará espero que todos participen en
esta elección de lo contrario es un
regalo para nuestros enemigos las
autoridades temen una abstención récord
el líder supremo el ayatolá alí jamenéi
critica regularmente los llamamientos
para boicotear las papeletas
muhammad y su hermano ali nunca se
pierden ninguno de sus discursos
entiendo que hay quejas pero no puedo
aceptar que esto se convierta en una
excusa para no votar espero que los
jóvenes animen a muchos otros a salir a
votar ante el tribunal
soy una persona religiosa sigo las
instrucciones de nuestro líder supremo
alí jamenéi dice que participar en la
votación es un deber pero muchos no
piensan como yo
durante las elecciones de 2017 más del
70% de los electores acudieron a las
urnas este año según los expertos la
extensión podría ser aún más alta
para analizar las elecciones
presidenciales en irán las
decimoterceras desde la revolución de
1979 conectamos a esta hora con josé
antonio egido él es analista
internacional y doctor en sociología por
la universidad francesa de provence a
señor ejido bienvenido a france 24
vemos que la abstencionismo amenaza los
comicios y muchos ciudadanos aseguran
que no importa a quien gane porque el
manejo del país será el mismo cuál es la
línea de estos cuatro candidatos
bien ahí había siete candidatos buenos
días para empezar desde donde hablo con
ustedes ha habido varios candidatos que
se han retirado en una carta a las
autoridades y se han mantenido cuatro
candidatos de los cuales uno el jefe del
tribunal supremo la parte que goza del
apoyo del líder supremo de la revolución
y pareciera que es la línea predominante
dentro de el pluralismo que existe
dentro de un sistema que combina la
pluralidad y la competencia política
ideológica y a la vez el respeto a la
línea ideológica musulmana establecida
en la constitución de 1979 salida de la
revolución islámica iraní no
líder del país tendrá como principales
retos levantar la economía completamente
diezmada por las sanciones
internacionales y darle un rumbo al
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 como se ve el
panorama con los candidatos que están en
contienda
mire aquí parece ser que había una
dificultad política entre la línea del
presidente saliente roja ni y la línea
que marca el líder de la revolución
entonces he escuchado un comentario hoy
desde teherán que señala que lo que va a
ocurrir es una mayor homogeneidad una
mayor cohesión entre luego gobierno sea
cual sea este y el líder de la
revolución de cara a resolver
favorablemente algo muy importante para
el país como es la vuelta a los acuerdos
con los norteamericanos y las potencias
occidentales y dichas del mundo del 2015
y poder reconstruir la economía y
reforzar la relación estrecha que tiene
el país con china y con rusia para para
atrás como como usted bien dice
reconstruir levantar la economía muy
afectada por las sanciones implantadas
por la administración trump desde el
2018 en que se salió de los acuerdos e
inmediatamente para que una política de
máxima presión sobre él
usted justamente estaba mencionando la
difícil situación económica que
atraviesa el país cómo se le da la
vuelta a esta situación realmente es una
alianza con sus con sus partidarios el
poder adquisitivo de los iraníes
realmente está afectado en este momento
sabe que el país tiene ese problema la
inflación muy grave los precios vuelan
pero no es la única amenaza tiene
amenaza en las fronteras la guerra del
año pasado entre armenia y azerbaiyán ha
sido un desafío la victoria de los
talibanes en afganistán es un desafío
para el país
israel amenaza continuamente al país ha
asumido la responsabilidad de atentados
terroristas contra instalaciones
estratégicas del país y el asesinato de
un científico de manera que hay
potencias extranjeras muy interesadas en
desestabilizar el país y la con las
sanciones y la inflación son
consecuencias directas de estas
sanciones que afectan al valor de la
moneda
pero es un país con bastante capacidad
tecnológica e industrial y es posible
que el escenario que salga vaya a
permitir junto con las esperanzas
puestas en las negociaciones de viena
los conversaciones de viena se
reconstruir la situación señor ejido
pues muchas gracias por su análisis
estamos muy pendientes de estos
resultados en irán en otras noticias el
número de refugiados y desplazados
internos alcanzó un nuevo récord a nivel
global durante los últimos 10 años la
cifra se duplicó y ahora se ubica en
82,4 millones así lo alertó naciones
unidas que explicó que pese a la
pandemia los números continuaron
creciendo el aumento fue de un 4 por
ciento durante el 2020 el primer grupo
de desplazados desde personas
procedentes de siria seguidos de
palestinos y venezolanos más romeros nos
cuenta más
millones de personas se vieron obligadas
a dejar sus hogares en un año donde la
consigna mundial era quedarse en casa
según cifras de la agencia de la onu
para los refugiados en 2020 hubo 82,4
millones de demandantes de asilo
refugiados y desplazados en todo el
mundo un 4% más que en 2019
a pesar de la pandemia que nos ha
obligado a todos a quedarnos en casa a
encerrarnos y confiarnos las tendencias
globales de desplazamiento forzado en
2020 fueron más altas que en 2019 3
millones más de personas ser y million
people more
la cifra no sólo aumentó sino que la
pandemia de kobe 19 hizo que los
desplazamientos fueran más peligrosos
borders jardín débil y ya está la
frontera se cerraron con firmeza sin
cruzar fronteras especialmente para
refugiados no desplazados internos y no
refugiados salva sus vidas en light
shading
la mayoría de refugiados y desplazados
parten de siria palestina y venezuela un
país que tiene a 49 millones de
habitantes fuera de sus fronteras
solo colombia alberga un cuarto de ellos
13 millones de venezolanos muchos de
ellos huyen de la pobreza uno de cada
tres niños venezolanos va a la cama con
hambre según cifras de la onu y las
donaciones internacionales han caído
también a raíz de la pandemia
acnur recuerda que hacen falta mil 440
millones de dólares para asistir a
migrantes y refugiados venezolanos por
ahora solo se ha recaudado el 5%
en perú el jurado nacional de elecciones
aseguró que trabaja a toda velocidad
para verificar los votos impugnados tras
la segunda vuelta de los comicios
presidenciales del 6 de junio lo que por
fin permitiría anunciar al vencedor de
la contienda cuando el candidato pedro
castillo mantiene el 50 como 12% de los
votos su contrincante keiko fujimori
volvió a señalar un supuesto fraude y
advirtió que el equipo de castillo
quiere manipular las elecciones por su
parte la presidenta del congreso mirtha
vásquez pidió calma y tranquilidad a la
población
en otras noticias desde la dictadura
cívico-militar uruguaya de 1973 quedan
muchas víctimas que piden justicia esta
semana se celebró una audiencia ante la
corte interamericana de derechos humanos
en la que los afectados pidieron que
aquellos que cometieron crímenes durante
las dictaduras durante la dictadura sean
procesados
alva santana tiene los detalles
reclaman verdad y justicia las víctimas
de la dictadura cívico-militar en
uruguay
exigen el procesamiento de los
responsables décadas después del golpe
militar los afectados todavía piden
justicia ante la corte interamericana de
derechos humanos ya que los autores de
los crímenes no han sido juzgados en la
república oriental de uruguay se precia
de ser una de las democracias plenas en
américa latina' y si bien tiene varios
motivos para hacerlo en lo que respecta
al pasado reciente uruguay mantiene
hasta el día de hoy una deuda que se
profundiza en cada día que pasa sin
respuestas concretas y efectivas desde
el 27 de junio de 1973 en uruguay se
cometieron crímenes contra la humanidad
el caso de las muchachas de abril es uno
entre tantos en diciembre del 74 tres
activistas de entre 19 y 21 años fueron
asesinadas tras recibir más de 200
balazos en un operativo de las fuerzas
armadas y la policía como ellas hay
muchas otras que sufrieron abusos
víctimas que ahora denuncian la
violencia a la que
tan expuestas las mujeres en estos
conflictos porque el cuerpo de la mujer
pues sí y es en este momento a un botín
de guerra ellos tenían un doble doble
castigo
primero por ser mujer
son algunas de las 28 víctimas que
llevaron su caso ante la cdh junto a
cientos de familiares de otras víctimas
que también exigen responsabilidades
torturas interrogatorios plantones son
algunos de los delitos que acusan y
contra los que los uruguayos han salido
a las calles en repetidas ocasiones a lo
largo de estos años pidiendo al estado
que responda ante estas acciones y
brinde justicia a las familias a
continuación otros hechos que son
noticia en el mundo los contagios y
muertes por kobe continúan disparados en
colombia además de los 29 mil 945 nuevos
positivos reportados en las últimas 24
horas el país registró 596
fallecimientos lo que deja el total de
casos en más de 385 millones y eleva a
98 mil 156 los decesos
bogotá continúa siendo el epicentro en
el país
israel anunció que transferirá a la
autoridad nacional palestina a cerca de
un millón de dosis de vacunas contra el
coi 19 que están a punto de vencerse a
cambio de una cantidad similar que los
palestinos esperan recibir en septiembre
de octubre el acuerdo fue anunciado por
el nuevo gobierno de israel que además
confirmó que cerca del 85 por ciento de
los israelíes adultos ya están
inmunizados
la capital rusa informó de nueve mil
cincuenta y seis positivos durante la
última jornada el máximo diario de
contagios desde el comienzo de la
pandemia ante el alarmante repunte las
autoridades ordenaron la vacunación
obligatoria del 60% de los empleados en
el sector de servicios pese a contar con
cuatro vacunas las inmunizaciones en el
país avanzan lentamente ante la negativa
de los ciudadanos a recibir las dosis
así vamos a dar un vistazo a nuestra
página web en este momento para ver lo
que titula
elecciones en irán candidatos
conservadores tensiones con occidente y
crisis sanitaria el análisis de esta
noticia así llegamos al final de esta
misión pueden repetirla y ampliar todas
las noticias en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]